today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza great block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles gray block
get that today's episode is also brought
to you by lakeside maple and I got to
tell you about something listen to this
and that's me shaking a pack of Link's
ID and maple baby and that is that
original trail mix you ever been lost
you ever been on a trail well mix that
up and put it in your face bucko that's
what I'm talking about lakeside maple
specializes in trail mix baked with pure
maple syrup a lot of time you see people
they got you know they say slang in some
low-key
you know back alley maple 30% maple 19%
maple well these bad boys over at
Lakeside or sling and trail mix baked
with pure maple syrup as part of our
small business support we are
advertising for lakeside maple to have
three flavors original spicy and ginger
chai all of their mixes are made by hand
and and they are fans of the podcast
it's a great snack if you're on the go
if you're running from someone it's a
great snack if you have a car and you
just want to just grab something to eat
real fast and you have nothing now you
have something that's lakeside maple go
to lakeside maple calm and use code Theo
at checkout for 15% off that's promo
code th EO at checkout for 15% off
lakeside maple get that mix and I love
their stuff man and I am so happy to
gave us some damn samples and I'm gonna
order a couple for myself and I mean
it's like birdseed for your damn soul
brother you know if we were Birds cuz
it's for it's for humans
today's guest is the he is the star of
the documentary psycho knotek's a comics
exploration of psychedelics and this man
went deep on those boomers this man was
snacking on those mushrooms you know
what I'm saying a messy enough
that's the the forests freckles that's
mushrooms baby in them things you put
them in your throat and who knows that's
when the Lord comes eavesdropping on
your soul baby that's when the Lord and
Satan get close inside of you and that
is what's happening in this documentary
this man took a bunch of mushrooms and
different drugs to go dude and he made a
documentary while he was doing it how
did he get there where did he end up did
he leave bread crumbs along the way this
is the psycho notic astronaut himself
mr. Shane moss
[Music]
my double-date podcast years ago I came
indeed your double-date podcast yeah yes
and I wanted to go on a date with that
girl
Samantha was her name I don't even
remember her I don't know who she was or
how he found her but I was like three
years ago yeah it was more than that yes
five years yeah yeah I'm flies yeah it
does fly huh it does yeah that's a new
new life new podcast new things going on
now yeah new things going on I just
watched your movie last night
psycho notic yes I can I cannot I cannot
except knotek's yeah yeah and so can you
tell us what a psycho knot is yeah
psycho nod is someone who uses
psychedelics to explore their own mind
and kind of views the internal world as
as a kind of universe onto itself that
is to be explored and I just want
hitchhikin inside of yourself yes
exactly and usually because there's
there's like you know micro dosers with
psychics that you hear a lot about on
yep and like Silicon Valley and stuff
and this is like take micro doses of LSD
to boost your productivity and
creativity and to me that's I've never
felt like that's what psychedelics were
about for me right um it was about the
bigger exploration so I I take like much
more like mega doses and really get in
there and explore those worlds and
sometimes a little too far as you saw in
the movie yeah and um I don't want to
spoil the movie for people I mean I
think you can say whatever thought it's
without spoiling it when you do you
weigh 10,000 Leagues Under the Sea
I did I got lost for a while it took me
it took me like a year to feel normal
again are you serious yeah because
that's like we had to after I I I mean
we start up the documentary by saying
this I ended up in a psych ward yes
but after that it took a long time I I
needed to basically we were done filming
after the psycho order like well I'm
[ __ ] gonna be crazy for a little while
and I can't do psychedelics anymore for
this first seeable future and so we had
to cut together what we had and I was
able to sort of record some voiceover
stuff and do some like post-production
stuff like that but but yeah it took me
a long time to come back to earth it was
it was ultimately one of the best things
that ever happened to me I feel like
because I got a full reset and now I'm
like I feel like I'm the best version of
myself I've ever been and I have a new
tour called stand-up science I have two
scientists in a different comedian on
every show in every cities a different
show and and that's going really well I
have my science podcast here we are is
going really well and it was it was I
quit drinking I quit smoking and yeah
those things that was really cool to
hear yeah you should drink a good bit
yes yeah oh I'm very comfortable saying
I used to get hammered all the time I am
an all-or-nothing I could see that yeah
and I'm a Binger I remember one time I
was walking it was at some Comedy
Central thing because we've kind of been
in comedy around the st. in the same
world you know the same you know you
know along the same timeline a little
bit Oh God we did didn't we do the same
wife at Gotham I think we did a the
Gotham yeah and DL Hughley was the host
yes yes
dude that was that was over ten years
ago we did that I remember the lights
went out during your set right yeah they
did and then and you had to redo your
jokes
yeah same audience you had to like re
perform your set like three times yeah
and his gay gentleman just runs up he's
like okay just start back over my car
start back over you little mongrel you
know yeah it was hell I know the power
went out just in the myth
so what he was gonna sort of trying to
play spin-the-bottle or someone like
tightness be the director but no there
was a years later I was at some party
and I remember it was some Comedy
Central it was a roast I think and it
was backstage or some somewhere and you
came walking in you didn't know I don't
think that out yeah I was on a different
level than you weren't like you were
knobbed out I think yeah you've been
drinking and you [ __ ] this I better
yeah yeah I used to fall quite a bit
I'll tell you I fall I fall less now
that I that I don't drink
also tongueless but though is the whole
thing when you don't drink it's hard
it's true it really is so that's the
there's pros and cons the trait that's
like cocaine man cocaine it's like you
know like if you were talking but is
like cocaine oh there's tradeoff cocaine
is a gateway drug you're talking
somebody's but definitely it's like you
do drywall than you do cocaine then you
tug it and the more cocaine you've had
the more but you'll have like oh yeah
well it goes hand in hand yeah I mean
you'll have a lot but it's just to like
be sober and get in there it's a lot
it's a lot of there's a lot of mental
barrier yes so enough did you notice
yeah you got a really it's almost like
you're telling us never mind of its own
really you know you have to you have to
you have to create some other scenarios
in your mind like this is just like like
a bag of pennies or something that I'm
that I'm tasting yes specialist in here
you know oh I think I left my wallet in
there so you're oh if you see my phone
you know I think you have to have some
reason to really put your tongue or just
lots of lots of alcohol and all of a
sudden it's just this delightful dish
like this is party time that's so true
but it's also easier to I think
investigate someone's but if you don't
know him that well you think so oh there
is there is if it's a stranger
I mean you would think it'd be the other
way around what you'd think you'd really
want to get to know somebody
ya know where they're been ya know like
what kind of diet they had a graze on
you see if they go to the gym but it's
the other way around it's that stranger
I mean I think it just goes along with a
danger it's like a real danger zone it's
the dangerous area and then after a
while you get to like respect someone
and whatnot that gets harder to tongue
there but - yeah it shouldn't be
don't you feel I don't feel like when
you're in like yeah a long term really
you're in love and stuff you're in a
coma and that's the only way I feel like
then yeah I think maybe you know getting
into there but yeah yes the doctor like
well that can they hear me well they can
Morris code sort of situation I want to
talk to you about the third year man no
but I love the documentary you working
with a guy that I know named brian
behlendorf who is hard worker oh my god
and a here's like he directed and edited
everybody Wow in a sweet soul and a hard
worker and I thought he was too sweet I
thought he was too naive into too much
of a nice house you did for the project
oh wow
because you know I wanted to make
something that was like a little bit
dangerous and a little bit you know a
real deep exploration of these worlds
and I and I wanted it to be a little bit
out there I wanted it to be like a true
exploration of what the world of
psychedelics is like and so go easy kind
of buttoned up you know yes he is he's
pretty organized pretty buttoned-up and
so you don't really you don't take them
for the type that if that's going to be
compatible but but
he had he had a good eye for practical
matters that I needed because I was I
really upped my psychedelic use through
the filming because I really I wanted to
be tapped into the world so I could you
know I it's the the best way to write
about psychedelics is to do psychedelics
and sit and write and and so I was
tripping a lot and I was starting to go
manic already and so I was getting all
these grandiose ideas of what I want and
I was trying to make like the inception
of documentaries like I wanted it to be
like a trip within a trip and I had
these really overly complicated ideas
that would have cost us so much money
right to implement them and this is as
the project just going on
yeah there's as the projects going on
and I'm I am I'm like but you don't
understand my vision and and was your
goal to prove to people because I love
the fact that it was it was your goal to
prove to people what like what was the I
mean we didn't really know when we
started the documentary okay so when we
started the documentary I was on they
the producer Matt Schuler you know but
he's he's he he makes a fair amount of
comedy specials and anyway he had he had
never made a documentary or anything
before and he heard me on Marc Maron's
WTF and he thought and he was already
familiar with my work but thought my
story was really interesting on there
and I was talking about the tour and
what I was doing and I had this 111 City
tour this like wildly successful indie
tour you know for me yeah yeah don't
like yeah still small venues both
selling out everywhere and and so at
first he was just like do you want to
make some kind of documentary we didn't
know because with my science podcast I
have a I don't even talk about
psychedelics that much it's like a
separate world for me
and so at first we're we're talking
about maybe some different science ideas
to explore and make it
you series or something like that about
and then I was like you know it's too
bad you didn't get to hold me earlier
because in like three weeks there's this
psychedelic conference in San Francisco
it's only once every four years and it's
the biggest psychedelic conference in
the world and every psychedelic
researcher is there and it'd be so easy
to get all these experts and so he loved
the idea and scrambled and we we
basically saw all the experts that you
see in it all it was was I saw I was I
was brought to the conference to perform
and and so I was starting to get known
in the psychedelic worlds already
because you've been doing the tour
because I've been doing the tour and
with my science podcast is kind of like
a way of legitimizing some of the some
psychedelic use and the psychedelic
research see you at the conference Matt
is there with you it starts to shoot and
all we did was we just took my hotel
room and turned it into a studio and and
got and just got every single like big
name psychedelic researcher that we
could to come in and just talk about
whatever they were interested in talking
about and afterwards you know after the
weekend we're like that's great now what
do we do right and I was like I guess I
do psychedelics and we film it I don't
know we didn't really know I never made
a documentary before and I didn't know
what the hell I was doing
and it's only Brian's second documentary
and and he had ideas of where he wanted
to go with it and it didn't really
resonate with me at the time Brian's
ideas one out thankfully I thankfully I
went crazy eventually and was completely
hands-off as Ike you guys got to finish
this without me I just got to work on my
mental health for a while so you start
dosing right you start taking it and
they're coming at certain days to shoot
with you and to see what you're doing
yeah well basically we had shoot days
like I went into a clinic to get a
ketamine trip for treatment for example
and but on all the unde off weeks I was
doing a lot of mushrooms just to like
stay in that world longer so I said just
so I could basically like come up with
interesting ways of our
pick you lating what we are looking for
and figuring out the direction of things
and in mice looking through the footage
and how to how to piece all of that
together and with the moments where you
started to like you were like it's been
I've done too much but you still had to
you felt like then now I have to keep
going well what happened was so I I
started doing regular amounts of
psychedelics when I went through I went
through a depression right at the same
time the documentary started I started
falling into like a really bad
depression and if my tour was coming to
an end and I wasn't sure what I was
going to do next exactly and I wasn't
sure about this documentary and if I
wanted myself portrayed like this and
oceans are like a sure way to they lose
your insurance provider lose your hunch
they're sure they're sure way to snap
out of depression if you're me right
they are the single best way to snap out
of a funk and and I always come up with
some creative ideas and and figure out
what my next project is going to be and
so I started doing mushrooms to get out
of the depression and it worked and came
up with ideas that I was really happy
with and I psych usually that's when I
stopped and I'm like okay I'm good for
another nine months or a year something
like that yeah I mean at that point
three three trips or something like that
but I was like why just be good I wonder
if you can feel like go from good to
great and so I like kept on doing more
mushrooms and is behind a Neil Armstrong
yes you looking at me [ __ ] Pluto dog
you looking to put rings around your
neck and I was feeling great and I was
like exercising a lot and that's when I
started like quit drinking and quit
smoking and I said I wonder if I could
feel fantastic like can we get out of
this solar system now so at what point
so and these are some times you guys are
shooting some of there's our meetup
didn't talking about this and and you
and you were just taking mushrooms here
and there now how much are you taking it
depended on my sometimes as little as
like two grams which is enough to make
trip that's a that's like the smallest
amount to trip up to like 10 grams which
is a like a pretty very large to 5 grams
is considered as terence mckenna's
heroic dose which I I don't think that 5
grams of mushrooms is that that much I
think 5 grams is just like you're
definitely going to be tripping yeah but
if you're by yourself like I do I trip
I'm like I wouldn't want to be on 5
grams and like navigate my way around
[ __ ] Bonnaroo or something like that
but if you're just by yourself on a
couch it's it's not a big deal would you
feel comfortable using a scalpel when
you're on a bunch of mushrooms or not a
scalpel sure why not I mean I've been in
the ocean many times on mushrooms I'd
say that's the most thing that many when
people hear you say that like well
that's dangerous but your body really
takes over for you and it kind of turns
off the mushrooms well you're in that
moment and then you go back out and you
start tripping again so I don't know
with mushrooms for me there's it's not
like like people usually think that's
like a bunch of hallucinations and stuff
for me it's like a sense of real clarity
oh yeah did I remember look Weezy go
find him and I took a whole bag of them
do probably no joke probably a quarter
of a gap of like a 60 gallon garbage bag
right like to a party and gave him to a
bunch people we started to give him a
hide-and-go-seek right who had never
taken him right so I get my I can go
seek while everybody's hiding like in
the woods and [ __ ] the cops come so
everybody had it just dispersed oh and
some people I think they never found
some people like some people [ __ ]
versus God oh I'm talking about the girl
that had never even liked giving
somebody a [ __ ] next thing you know
she's got [ __ ] 9 milligrams of
mushroom yeah
now they're hiding you know her own
[ __ ] bad breath yes second setting is
important for sure but um but so you so
you're taking these mushrooms escalating
your are you starting to feel like okay
I have to do this a little bit to keep
the vibe going we're doing the
documentary I'm all Lynne or we started
to get nervous that you were in it no I
was feeling great and then I did DMT and
I hadn't done DMT and Mike almost a year
as I've done DMT about a hundred times
but DMT started getting so strange and
so spooky and it was like predicting the
future like the product it or when you
took it it did like you when I took it
it would show me things about like where
I is going to be like the next time that
I smoked DMT so I put it so then the
next time like say I saw I've never been
in this room before right and so say
like six months ago I smoked DMT and I
see this thing that's like all of these
that's like this square like coding
thing with like some waviness here and
in some shape and almost like a figure
or something like that and I can't
really make sense of it but it's like
impressing upon me that this is
important to remember and then I'm here
and I smoked DMT right now in front of
you and pop out of it and look over and
it's this like in court this is like
what it showed me six months ago was
this painted and rice like how did it
know I was going to be in this moment
smoking DMT in a place I've never been
in and know like what was going to be
there and it started messing with my
idea of like is there free will if I
knew I was going to be here six months
ago then I had no free will between now
and that time there there is no I had to
have ended up here right and once I
started having those ideas I like this
shit's getting too spooky for me and so
I quit doing DMT in those ideas felt
very real though yeah like just as if
you know you would like you know say
that's a plant right there
like yeah that is a plaintiff felt very
it felt just as real as any of this does
yeah absolutely and so and that's so
freakin wild because you can only get
the clues when you go into the dmt yeah
only in the DMT and so then I and then I
smoked DMT for the documentary just
goofing around like well yeah I was
gonna put some [ __ ] rollerskates on
my amygdala hit the highway like the you
know the the scene that opens with me
like all painted and glowy art shed and
whatnot it was us just like goofing
around at the I was like just poking
around at this shamans place and she had
this glow in the dark stuff and and at
first we were just like like we just
painted like a glow-in-the-dark dick on
my face just because we wanted to just
take it like we were trying to like make
a joke of like how everyone takes these
things so very very seriously it's a
sacred thing and so I was I was just
looking dop guy with this [ __ ] dick
on his face like a [ __ ] frat boy yeah
and so we were just trying to make some
joke like that and then shot me smoking
DMT like all painted glow-in-the-dark
just to look like a [ __ ] lunatic and
and you and Nate did that get hairy that
experience and it did that's when like
DMT was like explaining that I was
supposed to be some communicator for
like DMT or something like it was like
it was like it knew it was like a I was
so you know I was I had started through
the documentary I started having these
Truman Show ish
I already had some Truman Show trips
where it was like this is all a [ __ ]
trick and this is all a show yeah I
think being in the entertainment
business you're susceptible to those
sorts of ideas a good point it feels
like that a lot out here anyway yeah and
and and then you're like I'm for example
eyes on ketamine and I had this like
this is the [ __ ] Truman Show than I
can use for killing animals in it it's
for its for its for no it's for sedating
animals so but not killing them what
about a lot of ketamine a lot of
ketamine might kill them I don't you
think a lot yeah no I don't mean [ __ ]
knuckles is going knuckles is going to
see the Lord boy cuz yeah I met some
girl doing ketamine in the elevator in
our building one night and I was like
you this is not you got to get indoor
somewhere else you know this isn't a
house as an elevator but okay so you're
at this lady's house your deep doubt and
the DMT this time what does it tell you
because it's like it's like this is this
place where you smoke it then you go
back into this experience and you get
almost updates from your previous and
next yeah and so it's like hey you
brought the cameras this is it you see
you're you're supposed to communicate
like oh no and I opened my eyes and the
cameras are all around me I'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on right now am I like
being used as some [ __ ] vessel to
like translate these things from this
other space which DMT if people don't
know is is these single craziest
experience that you can ever have it's
it's the single greatest mystery that
I've ever come across because it's the
DMT experience is nothing like this
world it's not even I mean people
compare it to being like a matrix like
thing because it's like an outer world
but the matrix has [ __ ] that looks like
this world like Keanu Reeves and [ __ ]
like DMT doesn't have it DMT doesn't
have like a single shape that is like
anything you've ever seen SMO colors
that even never seen before it's you
smoke it no is it like smoke like no
it's like fractal like and I guess it is
like geometric but it's a it's just so
foreign like all of the rules to this
world are
and you know they they don't apply our
physical laws don't don't work there and
you can have a 10-minute DMT trip that
feels like you're gone for like
thousands of lifetime oh yeah I've had
those then he come back I've completely
forgotten I was a human being before and
then they come back I'm just sitting on
the couch like oh yeah I'm a [ __ ]
shame this weird earth like this this
whole existence on earth feels like just
a sliver of the numbers of lives that
I've had when when you smoked DMT that's
what it feels like so do you think you
start to you start to feel the bigger
picture of existence or of being like
what I'm trying to think of the word
that would you know that you're more of
a like this is just one of your lights
along a whole string of Christmas lights
and and you know we're so focused in on
this light because it's all we know and
we're gripping to it and trying to stay
so alive and you know trying to live to
a hundred and eating held and this and
that but then you probably get to this
other vision and you see like oh this
doesn't he this is nothing this is yeah
it seems like there's a there's millions
of of parallel universes where you're
different it feels like this is just
that one channel that you're on right
any minute the channel can just flip and
you're just like a completely different
thing in a completely different
existence that's nothing like anything
else on in this universe it's just a
completely different universe with a
different set of laws of physics and
different things going on how cool would
that be man I it's [ __ ] frightening
to me because I always I mean I've been
and I was a pretty hardcore atheist for
much of my real life and I always felt
like a lot of comfort in death rather
than a lot of people being scared of it
Isaac oh I'm glad that existence and
it's at some point like existing forever
just seems like a [ __ ] nightmare to
me like it life might seem short but
imagine if you lived for a thousand
years or something like that
like oh my god what would I do with a
thousand years I'm telling the same
[ __ ] jokes watch the wire again yeah
yeah guess I'll be a barista for years I
got time to kill
you know [ __ ] shoot a bunch of people
I could do two life terms I'll be out by
370 exactly so it's just so the idea
that after this life that there's just
an infinite number of other [ __ ]
lives or if we have to be like you and I
got a [ __ ] swap next time and I knew
you're made of every single possibility
that there is has to exist and things to
be complete for things to be complete
and so so you have to be every single
person have to it has to experience
every single thing from every single
angle and every observable reality and
that [ __ ] is terrifying
didn't feel like it's exalt like it's
gonna be exhausting or does it feel
terrifying exhausting and terrifying and
and when I I mean when I finally lost it
really the main thought so that was
after so DMT started me down the path I
can imagine you thinking then you're
going in a little bit of alternate
worlds or you know different kind of
levels of perception which I'm able to
be like you know maybe these are just
these inner worlds in our minds and and
the reason why it seems like parallel
universes is because we all have to have
all these multiple simulations like I
have many different possibilities of
things that I'm going to do tonight
right for example going through my head
so I have these like five different
worlds of these five different
possibilities that myself on some level
in my mind are walking themselves
through through and for me to be able to
pick one of those choice yeah when and
so so for me I was like well that's
that's that's the most grounded thing of
what DMT could be is just that you're
going into these inner worlds that are
there for the running these simulations
to figure out what choices and it just
looks different when you're in there
because you're seeing it in just it's
like raw mathematical properties I say
you know where as you know our brain is
doing a lot of the work behind the
scenes that we're not actually able to
see in our present state right now so
but then so you come to the UQ you're on
this DMT and the cameras and stuff are
there so then I could imagine you're
like well [ __ ] these cameras are
capturing life yeah like it's a weird
thing that cameras do we don't think
about it that much but they capture life
and then represent it later how it wants
to be presented yeah and this is a lot
like what your memory does as well when
you search back in time it it you're
observing the past but a different
version of the past and what actually
happened you know eyewitness testimonial
and everything and specially a
storytellers we represent you know it's
like we represent it and yeah and we
create a new picture and then we and
then the story that we tell is is
influencing people's judgement of how
the story went down they have their they
create their own picture of the story
that you're telling now you got this
like weird game of telephone going on
for for this single moment that happened
by the time you express it to others
their version of it if you could like
DVR their brain and see what they were
seeing when you told the story and play
it against like a closed-circuit camera
of what actually happened those would be
two very different things in our inner
world has all these kind of multiple
realities to and it's not even och it's
not even that that it's it's an
inability for the brain to have an
accurate representation of memory it's
that the brain feeds your consciousness
a biased story of what happened to make
yourself like the hero in the story make
yourself like smarter or better looking
or a better driver or whatever these are
all testable things 70% of people think
that they're smarter than the average
population better drivers than the
average population that sort of thing
yeah and and the math doesn't add up and
so so the
the like when you picture a past event
the thing that's playing in your head is
recreated edited version of things and
then that's what we also do with
television right to things and we edit
things to make it look a certain way
even with the documentary is such an
interesting experience yeah I can
imagine because yeah you're having it's
like you're having that same experience
I'm like all these levels and then and
then I did ayahuasca and it and then it
was rice guy now who was was anybody
tapping you on the shoulder and all of a
sudden hey hey yeah you know step away
from the buffet of non waffles on your
ketamine yeah and that's and that's when
the ayahuasca was a wonderful beautiful
experience but I was actually going to
do ayahuasca on my own to get ready to
do it on camera that's what we didn't
show on the film that's why it's
actually going to we kind of portrayed
it like we were we couldn't get the
cameras industry but we we had figured
it out we were going to shoot me doing
ayahuasca but in preparation for that
because I have less experience with
ayahuasca why do we do ayahuasca first
course so I'd know how to do it on
camera and how to represent it well and
and that was when it was just like
showing me that I was like some
communicator of this like very important
message and I was to like get scientists
involved in building this like project
because this is information from these
future people where you're like a
[ __ ] in ER and once you start having
those ideas about yourself like that
[ __ ] runs away from you in a hurry and
then you start having these very
grandiose delusions and then and it's
not even fun having then like nothing
about me wanted to be like some some
grand communicator or anything like that
but but then you start feeling like
these responsibilities and
and so what I started thinking then was
how much of our inner world is just
metaphors for what is actually going on
in life like when we say so there's this
idea of embodied cognition which is
which is we use all of these physical
metaphors like we're having a deep
conversation right now or someone can be
shallow it doesn't mean anything it's
just that we're the cortex that does all
these fancy ideas was built on top of
the limbic system yep which does these
sensory stuff also how we old-school
stuff so how we interpret these these
grander ideas is through like these old
school raw so you call someone blue when
they're feeling sad like all this stuff
would seem to like a alien
anthropologist coming down and hearing
us communicate it would be very
confusing to them like to want to get
high right like why would high be better
than low you know but it is to us
probably because we evolved to fight
against gravity and so up seems better
you know heaven seems a hell seems down
and under us and and so these are all
these metaphor things and those like
well maybe everything's a metaphor and
what what if all of this existence is a
metaphor and at the same time this guy
was was taunting but was taunting Kim
Jong on with Trump oh this isn't Chris
Farley sorry
oh it's Chris Farley I thought it was
[ __ ] no I was like why do you have a
huge something that's hilarious well I
have the worst I was like why do you
larious yeah oh no that's Chris Farley
he's from Wisconsin I just need to see
it I just thought you had a hilarious
sad satirical painting of ours Brady
Matthews made this well at the same time
like there's all the nuke stuff going on
and I was like is this just like she
started to lose it yeah I was like is
that art is is what happens in our
internal internal is this is this all
just a metal metal
or for our own internal conflicts that
we have in the night I started thinking
about my own inner worlds like say say
you have right like his liver Trump and
is my yeah well more more like say so I
just had my my friends one of my best
friends just had his first baby and like
a couple days ago and when they were
going into the hospital I was like oh my
gosh I hope there's no complications
during the during the birth and then but
because I had that thought because the
brain runs these simulations of events
having that thought then does that mean
in some level in my mind I've created
this world bility where she does like
die during pregnancy or something like
that and now I just created that so on
that level of something that is like
real with in my head like as real like
how real our dreams really because you
feel them they they seem very salient
and then do you think you could go into
that world and save the day
yeah and so it's like well how do I so
then I'm like every idea you have that
kind of morphs into like a bigger
picture idea you think that that's
reality that could be an alternate
reality an alternate reality of that um
and then no and so now I'm trying to
like not think because because it's just
really help everything every time you
think you're starting a whole new
existence yeah you have to then go be in
and it's this worst-case scenario and
now I'm figuring out how to fix the
problems that I've created in my own
mind of these worlds that I'm creating
and and then I'm just creating more and
more and it just doesn't stop and there
was something oh my god like dude that
is overwhelming to think about it was
overwhelming to experience and I stayed
up for three weeks I didn't sleep
through do that life-or-death situations
happening and and you know this is like
we're
are depending on me solving this like
given to convince people of this cuz
you're [ __ ] manic at this point oh and
like anyone that would listen know where
we know I was just like wearing my
girlfriend down you know I was basically
just I was cautious not to because if I
told someone and if they were like what
the [ __ ] can I think I bet they're in on
it right my borders is all like because
every young woman kind of like that kind
of [ __ ] everyone's being everyone in my
life is like nudging me in a certain
direction so if I'm getting like too
close to the answer then like like
someone someone Chipotle reading way too
much into everything and then and then
my and then there was no differentiator
between my imagination and what was
reality like I just could I could not
tell the difference and so I know I know
what it's like to be a [ __ ] crazy
person I get it I get it when people are
[ __ ] ranting and raving about like
seeing [ __ ] aliens or being other
dimensions or whatever the [ __ ] that
they're seeing now when I pass someone
that's experiencing Lee I'm like [ __ ]
man been there buddy do you feel like
you can go approach one of those people
and discussing with them out or you just
realize they're alright always thought
maybe like you're like Cesar the dog
whisperer schizophrenia I kind of want
to try but I I'm still I'm worried that
I'm still worried about that because
I've had a couple manic episodes since
that first one and not not any wearing
right but yeah I've had you're like if I
try too much to skirt to flirt with this
time line am I gonna get lost like I
don't I don't talk about this [ __ ] like
outside of situations like this and I'm
very careful to like not let myself
think about these ideas too much now
how's my brain will start just running
away with itself and and then all the
sudden billboards are talking to me
specific yeah it's like it's like every
so you know how we're talking right now
in everything that we're saying
resonates with each listener and each
audience member at a different level
it's like sometimes when you're in that
state you hear something and you hear a
song and it's like there's a certain
level of resonance that was exactly for
this moment at this exact time and even
the person communicating it didn't know
it it's like if someone's listening to
this right now
and this just reaches them at the
certain level like they are talking
exactly to me right now and I don't
understand how this is happening and
that's how you feel all the time on the
thing yeah yeah yeah like everything is
everything is always all a metaphor not
every bit but like throughout the day
that happens like 10 times in a day and
yeah and even when I'm trying to unlike
this is confirmation bias you know this
is I'm just looking for things to
validate but it's like it's like if
you're listening to the radio and all of
a sudden there's a song that's just like
there's a man named banana costume
dancing across the street in front of
you and then you look over and there's a
guy in a banana costume dancing in front
like what the [ __ ] is going on right now
and that's what it felt like oh that's
all like very specific stuff all of the
time but the thing is is the brain can
associate anything with anything right
so just your brain looking at it sounds
like yeah your brain is just just
literally pedal to the metal yeah
everything is going so yeah and
everything's connected and and I mean
everything everything in your brain is
connected at some level and right I'll
work off of this associated memory and
that's how we we to understand anything
you need to have kind of these trigger
points that associate like if you go
there's this comedian from he was bigger
I think he's from the Midwest he he did
like a song about a home Oh
Chris Farley you know and that's what
happens when things are at the tip of
your tongue it's so your brain hasn't
made enough associations yeah and then
like when you stop thinking about it for
a while your brain keeps on
working and finding those associations
and then he triggers it like unlocks
that bit of information once enough
associations have been made okay as
scientists think there's like four or
five associations needed to trigger a
memory and they've you tell us a bunch
on like people with Alzheimer's and say
hey so what's it in between them when
you're on you're under the influence of
these and not on the influence of these
so the difference is is that is that so
I just mentioned those like four or five
associations to trigger like the chris
farley right idea in my head but then
each of those things like being from the
Midwest having a song about home all
those things have five different
associations of their own and then each
of those things have five different
associations of their own so it's this
tree of Association that keeps on going
deeper and deeper into the mind and when
you're in that state you there is no
sense of any level it's just all one
thing that's just all one connected
thing so like your tree of connectivity
is just going is extending itself way
too far so far it's just this confusing
mess Wow yeah
Wow your buddies naked you should change
that up well I'm here to tell you about
stitch fix stitch fix is an online
personal styling service that finds and
delivers clothes shoes and accessories
to fit your body budget and lifestyle
just go to stitch fix dot-com slash Theo
and tell them your sizes what styles you
like and how much you want to spend on
each item you'll be paired with your
very own personal stylist who will hand
pick items and sin right to your door oh
wow that's interesting so you put in
your body style you know I got that baby
you know I got those baby shoulders man
I got that you know I got the rib cage
of a large cat and I got the des bootie
and I would put all those into there and
I would say Who I am and what I am and
styles I like and then stitch fix would
mail things to my house that maybe what
I would enjoy then you try them on pay
for only what you love and
the rest shipping exchanges and returns
are always free there's no subscription
required you can sign up to receive
scheduled shipments or get your fix
whenever you want
stitch fixes styling fee is only twenty
dollars which is applied toward anything
you keep from your shipment so get
started now at stitch fix comm slash
Theo and you'll get an extra 25% off
when you keep all the items in your box
so take that challenge try it all on do
you love it then keep it and get 25% off
all the items in your box or just keep
what you love that's stitch fix dot-com
slash Theo to get started today it's a
new dressing and budget and lifestyle
experience stitch fix dot-com slash Theo
support this past weekend and so is it
at the moment before you go into the
what do you what did you tell the
documentarians when you're like I'm
[ __ ] guys like I called him and I was
like I was like are you guys is this a
trick like are you they were working for
was it the Chinese will you be honest
with me right now are you working with
the Chinese that would have been amazing
if I would have called my producer or
the director been like are you working
these are definitely doing this I mean
if anybody could do it it's the Chinese
bro you know I was over there somebody
died they [ __ ] made soup out of the
guy and [ __ ] kept it move and dude
[ __ ] they're just keeping going bro but
yeah you gotta keep moving
oh they're trying to definitely create
little tiny people right now to live in
your [ __ ] soul brother some guy to
just go [ __ ] pickaxe and up your
spine to get all you see you say there's
like a negative thing I'm like that's
amazing they're developing the
technology I I mean then you can create
little mini use to get into your own
soul to feel that's it's too much it's a
little bit Milkovich no - [ __ ]
Malkovich Malkovich yeah a little you
has a couple mushrooms bro that is [ __ ]
it's over
did you so what did you tell him who do
you think it was oh I didn't know I mean
I thought this was all some joke that
myself on some other reality was playing
on myself like I I kept on waiting for
there to be like a surprise like
remember you created all of this [ __ ]
for you to appreciate but so ok so then
if you start to think it is possible and
it's all some sort of like you know you
know deep space kind of intricate but
safe this a game like this risky riddle
that your what about like using the
bathroom and things like that that must
have seemed like well this would be a
weird thing to incorporate into the
[ __ ] mate to the trick I mean I was
obsessed with the amount of suffering
like if this is some game or some trick
well then what about all the people
suffering in the world what the [ __ ] is
that for and if I built that like if I'm
responsible for building that and
putting that in the system it's like
it's like when you make a simulation you
play a sim or whatever the first choice
is you play the hero right and then
after that you play like maybe you play
the bad guy instead so you play like
these main characters they're the most
interesting and then after you've been
playing the game for long enough like
it'll play second in charge and maybe
I'll play this guy see from that point
of view and then after a while you play
the [ __ ] dude that you shot in
another version of the game so you
that's how you have empathy for and then
you play the [ __ ] prostitute that you
[ __ ] boned in the in the earlier
version oh and a brothel yeah some party
yeah and and so you got that slave every
character kitty yeah and so this is like
so at the end of this life if there's
just like a real letter e wheel and
you're going to end up and someone else
then the first
that you want to do is focus on the
people that are the worst in the worst
case position and make sure and elevate
them right so that you sure [ __ ] don't
end up like living in the streets or or
worse you know and and so I I just kind
of became obsessed with with poverty and
violence and more and like just more
more than the most usual more than was
healthy more than I had when you later
yeah yeah like you're going home with
guys and being like hey you know yeah
how do a lot of homeless people have
spoke of swords bro first job homeless
people it seemed like they were like
communicating with me when I was manic I
would like walk past a homeless guy and
they would like say something like they
see you now there's some [ __ ] like that
I'd be like what the [ __ ] it was like
schizophrenic people were able to like
yeah give me clues and like speaking of
[ __ ] different language that made
sense to me in that moment like they're
all gonna know you did it and I'm like
oh [ __ ] I was just thinking about like
what if I'm responsible for like the
this look like an aspect of the human
suffering and then and then some [ __ ]
schizophrenic guy on the streets like we
see that you did it and like I mean
they've just been saying that that to
the last thousand people because we all
have [ __ ] that we're worried about your
brain is so active in the tree is
running so deep and every neuron is
connected no matter what they say yeah
that's different yeah Wow yeah so you
snapped you lost it I lost it completely
that's awesome and [ __ ] jealous bro
yeah I came back you know and now where
did you go when they took you in did
they take you an ambulance or not no no
I went to the I mean I went to the
hospital three times so the first time
would they say I'm the first time I was
like to appease my girlfriend and I
hadn't slept in a couple weeks I went in
like talked to a doctor
and what are you eating during this
sorry I what kind of snacks raisins like
I feel like Oh what kind of snacks are
you I was not prepared for this question
I didn't think in all of this you're
gonna ask what kind of snacks you lose
your mind
jerky beef jerky seemed like it would be
tough and just great like just no I mean
that's like you got to get that pro well
that was another thing to like I had
empathy for every single thing but it
wasn't just animals it was like [ __ ]
plants and everything else do they have
sentience and I'm like there was times I
can I even eat this [ __ ] Apple right
now does this [ __ ] app is everything
alive as his parents know they eat it
Wow
yeah so there was actually now that you
asked me about it there was a little bit
of that where it was a little high
sometimes I I was in this [ __ ] worm
tunnel where I couldn't eat anything
because everything had a [ __ ] a life
of its own and so what was life eating
itself would it be a granola bars of
like that was okay at the time I could
see that bar yeah it's very like because
it feels like just science made the
barbecued chip it doesn't it doesn't
feel like there's a lot of life involved
there it feels like a very manufactured
feels like making making like plastic
yeah something like that
oh yeah just like class it's like
artificial food like yeah yeah and you
can eat that without feeling too bad for
yeah but but yeah I remember
I planted a potato that was like growing
and spouting on top of the fridge I was
like this thing's trying to [ __ ] grow
I got a [ __ ] foot give that take this
baby home [ __ ] scooping up soil in
the yard
what are some other small ventures that
you started I love this was it did you
start any small businesses no I mean my
time was dedicated to understanding time
travel and how and I kept on thinking
The Closer that I got to understanding
it I was like furthering the ideas to
actually making it happen and so because
whatever I was stumbling upon which was
information from these DMT worlds that
they were giving to me as basically I
was like going back through all of my
DMT experience with this new set of like
these were instructions for how how time
works and once I was like getting an
idea that I thought was like in line
with how you could manipulate time that
that would eventually that idea would be
furthered like thousands of years or
whatever and because that idea was like
the butterfly effect of of creating that
that was like sending something back a
ripple back through time it was [ __ ]
you like that was [ __ ] me up so that
I couldn't do it and so like every time
I completed the puzzle a new puzzle took
over I remembered when eyes eventually
in the psych ward I remember I closed my
eyes at one point and these puzzles just
started forming in my brain and it was
like trying to lock my consciousness and
inside it was it felt like get out or
something like that it felt like the
movie get out it felt like a puzzle
trying to like lock me inside of my own
mind so I wouldn't have so something
else could take over that was a scary
thing it felt like it felt like this
whole time that I've been smoking DMT to
tap into these because for years like if
I was like well what do you guys want me
to do when I'm in these other worlds it
felt like I was meant to just like
figure out how to keep this opening open
for longer so like more information
could be passed through or something for
that but this whole time I thought I was
tapping into this other universe I
didn't realize it was actually them
tapping into me Wow and trying to go
into my world I thought I was going into
their world this whole time it was a
two-way street and I felt this [ __ ]
thing like trying to take over my
[ __ ] mind I would wait when I did
fall asleep I made me fall asleep for
like thirty minutes or something like
that and I would you know like in a kung
fu movie when someone's on their anak so
knocked over on their back and they
spring back up on their feet that's how
I was waking up I was springing out of
bed like that in like a [ __ ] karate
stance like feeling like I was under
attack and it was it was a lot wow that
guy really he did a lot of dope didn't
he well if you have done drugs or other
things or just have never really gone to
school then I recommend Skillshare
Skillshare it is a sponsor of this past
weekend Skillshare it's an online
learning community for creators are you
creative will quit screwing around doing
nothing raking the yard complaining a
mom about you know not enough ham and
the ham pack well Skillshare offers more
than 25,000 classes in design business
and more you'll discover countless ways
to fuel your curiosity creativity and
career quit thinking you need to go to
four years of college do you might just
need 40 minutes to brush up on some new
skills and get out there and make a
difference get creative you can take
classes in social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing or even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start a side
hustle or gain professional skills
Skillshare is there to keep you learning
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for our listeners get
two months
dos Manos of Skillshare for free that's
right Skillshare is offering this past
weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 25,000 classes
full free to sign up go to Skillshare
comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare comm / th EO vo n
for your two months now that Skillshare
comm / Theo von and now back to this
dope boy how is it now at the house
how's the sex drive is there any sex
traveling on this kind of deal no I mean
I was so crazy like my girlfriend had no
interest in having sex with the [ __ ]
crazy guy but there was there was no
there was kind of like you to masturbate
you or anything to try and like calm you
down I did a little bit such a dude
trick no matter what realm were in we're
gonna [ __ ] jerk off over here what's
up my car ran out of gas so does jerked
off outside this young you know file you
know that's like when you had so much
calm in your body you could do whatever
you wanted I'm saying I could [ __ ]
you know now that now was there ever
some weird moments where if you jerked
off you're like oh [ __ ] this is the
secret sauce
there was dude okay so oh my god I can't
see I haven't even thought about this in
[ __ ] months because this was like a
year and a half ago thinking about stuff
when I used to [ __ ] be young and
eating mushrooms did I remember taking
all my clothes off one time and driving
my car you know and my all my body
turned red on my skin on the blood came
to the surface of my skin and it turned
all red and I [ __ ] then I got in the
back seat because I was looking for
something then I started [ __ ] jerking
off and then my seats like a real
problem solver I was looking for the
[ __ ] truth right and I thought the
truth was under my [ __ ] car seat
right so I pushed the car seat forward
and it landed on the hood no on the horn
of my front seat so this was like a Ford
Escort like 1984 so it like hit
the horn the horse anomalous the horn is
just going and then my buddy's mom
[ __ ] came out there yeah that shuts
it all down bro you want to know who's
the one stopping all this kind of
behavior it's moms I felt like I felt
like it was at one point I had the idea
see not like we all have imaginative
ideas yeah and then we're like oh I just
imagined that idea but when I was in
this state if I imagine an idea like
this is [ __ ] reality and I I need to
explore this idea to like to its to its
logical [ __ ] conclusion and so at one
point it was like well maybe how these
ripples are being sent back in time is
that is that this is there's information
being passed through our DNA and so
maybe the reason why I'm being
threatened is because I've been choosing
not to have kids but I need to have kits
outlet that was when my girlfriend first
was like when I was like we need to
elope and have a baby and she was like
now you gotta go to the hospital yeah is
what it because you never [ __ ] talk
about marriage and having kids that's
why I know you're real [ __ ] crazy
when you're talking about eloping and
[ __ ] having babies but so then it was
like it was like that's how it was
tracking me through time was through
like it was it was once you can once you
can figure out the the mechanics of
every single thing once we learn and we
can make predictions about every single
thing and where it's going to be then
you can then you can work back in time
through where every man molecule was and
so I was thinking that I was leaving
like bread crumbs through time with like
my DNA like oh if I if I [ __ ] jerk
off leaving Clues everywhere he'll you
know just like somebody just come and
just and running through the pages of an
Agatha Christie novel so to skip around
a little bit I remember
for heaven this idea occurred to me
again when I was in the psych ward I
feel I felt like there's this [ __ ]
there's this [ __ ] lady in there this
crazy lady who like if you came in here
you would get what no no [ __ ] it was
like it was like if I [ __ ] came down
the drain like I wasn't jerking off
because I didn't want it to like find me
right but it was like I was trapped in
this [ __ ] I was never gonna be let
out of here
but if I came back it would send it yeah
they'd like be able to find it and like
they'd Sally something back in time to
know where I was so that someone would
come to get me out of this [ __ ] psych
ward man and so I go to [ __ ] jerk off
and push our train and this to leave it
was like [ __ ] with my head to leave
clues as I [ __ ] came down the shower
drain I
oh it was like it was like I needed to
like this was insurance right that I
would be able to be found in the future
and that was what I was like this is
insurance and I'm right it's like a note
it's like a message in a bottle and so
as I [ __ ] come and down this drain I
just hear this lady yell like a good
neighbor is happening right now
cuz I had this whole [ __ ] idea that I
was like being farmed like my DNA
oh the insurance yeah and the insurance
and everything like what the [ __ ] is
going up because that was the other
thing when I was in the psych ward at
one point is it nice and there or not
well it's not bad
it's just that you don't have a sentence
so you don't know how long you're in
there like they're not like we sentence
you to three weeks in the cycle you
don't know if you're gonna be in there
for [ __ ] forever or for a couple
hours you have no idea
Sonic is this the rest of my life now
and like my [ __ ] parents put me in
there and
and like my girlfriend and I'm like
thinking they're against me so the
people that are the closest to me in my
life are the ones that put me in the
psych ward so now I can't trust them and
things get [ __ ] hairy when you can't
trust anybody and then you're in a
situation like that and you have no idea
like if they're ever gonna let you out
and then I'm like I'm thinking this is
like all the [ __ ] roofs and this is
this thing that's been constructed just
to store my [ __ ] consciousness away
like I knew it like when I thought like
everyone was after me and then my to me
from my point of view
everybody was everyone turns on me right
this [ __ ] gang deals in the same
manner and now there's people like
looking at ya with a [ __ ] clipboard
and [ __ ] and then I'm doing like crazy
[ __ ] like like I thought maybe - I
thought they were speaking of editing I
thought they're like using you know
they'd they would show my family like
footage of my behavior to like make me
look crazy and like edit it because I
was thinking about editing a lot eat it
up and and make it stick your hands yeah
yeah make it look like so I wanted to
[ __ ] with their continuity so I kept on
like changing and stuff like that and
doing weird things to say like I would
like rip off my [ __ ] yeah band and
like put a different one on right into a
beer and be like and I would like and
where they fill me or the documentary
people filming you at this time all
wrong no they were nice Ward yeah you
can't be like hey we're shooting this
documentary can kill my friends I know I
know I mean but what do you do I mean
that's not that's not part of the
process to getting what look no psych
wards gonna be like sure that sounds
like fun
come on in here did you meet anybody
else when you're in there uh yeah I mean
that was the strangest thing was
everyone felt like it was like a very
Wizard of Oz kind of feeling like
everyone felt like this is the strawman
version of of this person this is the
iron [ __ ] dude of this version of a
purse of a person and so it was like
they all reminded me of somebody and I
remember I like cleared off this
whiteboard to to like draw these ideas
of how I thought time worked and I said
I better not draw that because somebody
will see it someone will see it and
think I'm crazy and they keep me in here
for longer when when I did that I went
to take a nap and when I woke up all
these [ __ ] crazy people in there had
drawn all the [ __ ] that I was going to
draw I'm not [ __ ] lying and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is hat and they drew it
better there's a skirt 3d artist in
there who is this amazing [ __ ] artist
oh yeah drew it way better than I ever
could of and it was all these of DNA
like passing through time sorts of
things it was like all the [ __ ] same
ideas that I was having these [ __ ]
dudes and the cyborg people having to
we're having the exact I had a crazy mom
that had to be so [ __ ] terrifying I
didn't know what was gonna so then I'm
like is this all just in my head am I
just integrating right now is this all a
dream like what is how do you
differentiate like when you're in a
drawer imagine you don't know it and
that's just your brain we could have a
dream I have a dream tonight and we're
sitting here having the same thing and
I'm having the exact same I'm do it that
means my brain is making a perfect
impersonation of you yeah like looks
like you it's a very convincing it's my
brains writing the script of the [ __ ]
things that you're saying and you don't
even realize that it's happening that's
how powerful our brains are oh yeah and
the brains a wild man Slytherin and then
it can change the dream just like that
yeah suddenly fly on a plane you know
what I'm saying and all those you know I
always had happening all the time
running all the time and it might just
be that your consciousness is jumping
around onto those different levels so
when when you're like being chased by a
shark or something like that in a dream
it might be that your consciousness just
popped down to that
in that reality you had been living a
whole life and then it was like in this
[ __ ] terrifying moment is when it
needs your consciousness it needs your
attention most and that's when your
consciousness shows up so maybe maybe
those [ __ ] worlds maybe there's just
like in thousands and thousands of
worlds going on in our minds all of the
time and our consciousness is just
skipping around between them you and
looked mm-hmm sure sure was but I came
back so as far as I can tell
did it really is crazy it's yeah it's
like you're a psycho not man it really
feels like you went when all the way I
can't imagine it gets much deeper than
that
I can only fathom the moment you thought
you were gonna draw something I'm not
gonna draw it because these people might
think I'm crazy and I got to get out of
here at some well I gotta at least trick
them even if I'm you know or just not
and then you go to sleep and you wake up
and somebody's [ __ ] drawn it and drawn
it better and then you're like well net
and like furthered my ideas like am I
crazy are they crazy it's just like some
[ __ ] are we all tapping into the same
idea the same idea thing and if there is
this universal consciousness like what
does that but like what does what does
it mean yeah what and while it would be
living like this and why so are all just
a metaphor for something like a and are
all of our lives just like do all of our
lives just have a moral to it is that
all like when this universal
consciousness needs to like make a
decision about something if it just goes
like oh remember the Theo
remember the Theo lesson and it's just
like has your whole life boiled down to
like a little sentence a little moral to
it that it taps into when it needs to
[ __ ] make a decision when it's like
driving the [ __ ] spaceship or
whatever the [ __ ] is going on
who knows you know I have no [ __ ]
idea
Gigi are you fully better now I mean I'm
on medication yeah yeah I saw that at
the
so funny hey cuz I'd say I mean I just
think antidepressants or something you
know I take that stuff I've taken it for
a long time but yeah what uh yeah I mean
is that I mean it keeps me from going
manic and yeah I mean see it's like
mania like a is it not like WrestleMania
is and I mean it's first off so I've
been bipolar to my whole life oh wow but
I bumped me up to bipolar one
so once the big one and two is like this
really hyper productive I mean you can
be careful because people like blow a
lot of money and stuff when they saw
that that's how you guys talked about
but but it's usually I'll be manic for
like two weeks and all right you know
and my my next hour of material like
most most of the big shows that I
putting together were just two weeks of
mania and I put together a thing that
you know was my income for the next year
or two of my life so do you think
there's some VAT so there's some value
in the mania oh absolutely
so it's almost like you need to be a
miner of the mania yeah I mean the it's
it's like when I'm when I manic at least
it feels like I have like 20 more IQ
points and I have like this incredible
happen and I'm super creative and
whether that's true or not it's
certainly what it feels like right and
and I am insanely productive during
those times so yeah if there's like a
safe way to channel that energy and tap
into it it'd be you know this is gonna
be something that I'm going to have to
figure out with my life as as like are
there really safe ways to tap into this
without without fully going into like
the truman show universal consciousness
and getting lost in and that yeah and
that abyss am do you feel like you were
pretty close to getting lost forever no
I never it always felt like you don't
think you always hear that story growing
about the guy he took nine hits
acid or something uh you know they you
know he thinks he's in orange now you
know it always heal me it always felt
like yeah it always to me it always felt
like there was a part of me and actually
a bigger part of me that was logical and
knew what was going on and knew that I
was just experiencing this kind of bout
of craziness it was just that it it
wasn't even that most of me thought that
any of it was true most of me thought
that it wasn't true it was just like if
there's even a sliver of a chance that
any of these ideas are true then the
cost involved is is just too big like if
if the thoughts and ideas that I'm
having it in this manic state are
something that are eventually like
triggering nuclear war or something like
that then the even if I think that
there's a point zero zero zero zero one
chance that that's actually happening
because it that seems like a crazy
[ __ ] idea but if there's a chance
that that is happening then that's like
unacceptable right and you do it anymore
because you just causing too much right
so I'm causing too many ripples and
whatever where'd you come whenever you
were doing all the we jerk and AH like
you said you've got to come down that
shower shower stuff even clues you put a
DAB on the [ __ ] door stop that's what
I would do I feel like the [ __ ] leave
a little [ __ ] on song you know on
Sam's elbow over here you know I mean I
feel like it has a way of leaving itself
yeah yeah I feel like you don't need to
try too hard
yeah the message spreads itself the
devil's Ellmers at all like yeah if you
and you don't want to know you don't
want to know where you can be [ __ ]
tortured for the [ __ ] answers you
know later on come on where did you
leave it good semen is pretty much you
know it's
that's the devil's Elmer's brother it
really is it really is now how long are
we in the psych ward for only seven days
really yeah that's it do you like it let
you out a little early like what did you
leave me like [ __ ] I should maybe stay
in a little longer
I mean I think that uh you know I was
fortunate that I knew like on an
intellectual level I knew a lot of this
kind of stuff and I knew about mania and
I write and you know I have a science
podcast I have an understanding of
neuroscience and and so I was able to
just use what I know to kind of talk
myself out of there and I kind of just
learned to shut my mouth and clean up
after myself and keep to myself and not
you know
drawler saying it like don't watch the
[ __ ] TV because the TV's always
[ __ ] talking to you right clue and
and yeah yeah stay away from the [ __ ]
clues and think you're a girl wanna bang
when you got out I kind of forget I
think maybe a little bit fine cynical
dude will [ __ ] anybody bro girl reflects
some dudes just gotta have a middle
hello Institute bro think about that you
know and I'm not judging your your
girlfriend and all I'm sure she's I've
seen you with some of the women you
dated beautiful talented women but yeah
chicks for [ __ ] I'm do this guy out of
a day middle I'm not doing that okay so
let's talk about that you're banging a
lady that just walked out of the psych
ward psych ward we're not [ __ ] there
no that's good down standards like that
for the door stop oh yeah I'm not
[ __ ] wasting a batch of clues on you
giving crazy all your secrets yeah I
don't want to [ __ ] it I'm now I might
blow a bag of red
[Laughter]
we had some calls we had some calls and
questions that came in for you saying
dude man I feel like I could just sit
here and kind of you know spelunk
through this mmm this stuff that you
went through in these moments and these
smell can you sing it all together whoo
it all together let's get to why Cynthia
from Texas and I had a question for
saying so with the psychedelic drug how
could you compare that to something that
is not drug like you know like sex or
like a roller coaster or something like
that
I'm curious um I've never done drugs
I've never been drunk even you know
never smoked anything never dabbled in
the dark arts like Theo does so I'm just
curious of uh how how you can compare it
yeah well I mean it's it's certainly
nothing like alcohol or cigarettes or
like coke or any like stereotypical drug
those are all like kind of escapes from
the mind and psychedelics are definitely
more of a inward exploration so I would
say it's closest to like meditation and
mindfulness stuff I would I would say if
you meditate enough you can get to some
of the same sorts of places as you can
with like micro dosing right I would say
you're not gonna go deep down no you're
not gonna go deep but yeah I would say
it's it's like the closest second
compared to is like a Christopher Nolan
movie or something like a interstellar
inception or something like that like a
real a real head [ __ ] of a for hours
yeah I don't know I mean that's that's
that's the that's the that's the trick
that's why that's why I was doing so
many psychedelics to figure out like how
do you communicate what these
experiences are actually like yeah I've
spent years trying to figure that out
so did Bill W man from Alcoholics
animus you know he was a deep diver you
know allegedly anyway and I think that's
pretty fascinating that he was just
trying to figure it out you know I'm
trying to you know get in there and just
you know take all take in what was
happening when he was you know under the
influence of psychedelics but at the
same time see how he could maneuver in
order to better himself you know or
better learn for humankind kind of do
you feel like there is a exploration an
inner exploration that is possible for
humans through a lot of these drugs now
or do you feel like it's just a series
of kind of you know similar loops and
stuff no I think that I think that
psychedelic research is out of all of
the topics that I cover on my podcast I
would say that psychedelics are the
things to me that seem like they have
the most potential that are the least
they're not studied because they're
Schedule one drug right and so it's very
very difficult to study them but I think
that they show the most potential in
terms of increasing empathy in the world
and treating depression PTSD those sorts
of things I think that they're I think
that they're incredibly useful and I
don't think that you know even though I
got lost out to sea and you hear about
other people doing that I don't think
that's like it's certainly not the norm
and I'm not sure that it's anything to
even worry that much about because I was
pushing myself to do more psychedelics
than I was comfortable doing and I've
been doing psychedelics for at the time
like over 20 years we do any
suppositories or anything like that or
no oh no you know I've never done a
suppository psychedelic I would I'd
happily do a do a but trip yeah yep and
they used to call it sometimes girls
would put a hit answer in their vagina
when I got high school I mean I'll stick
some in my appeal yeah I'll stick a
little a little LSD in my urethra see
where it takes me sure Jesus right bro
take you know that will take you the
hospital for sure kennel you
think LSD in the pee hole and you're
going to a kennel that's gonna burn
brother that's gonna burn I think it's
gonna burn man that's straight in the
[ __ ] piss hole ah I think it'd be
okay yeah you might wake up and [ __ ]
who knows bro go stuck LSD in the peel
we got another one from Mexico what type
of person would best be suited to go
deep to go deep to really get in someone
with lots of mindfulness training like a
yogi or something like that would be the
best person to like if you're if you're
drafting like Psychonauts to go and put
them in like MRI machines and and give
them like mega doses and see how far
they can go
someone with tons and tons of
mindfulness training would help a lot
someone that can really detach
themselves into into that observer role
and just kind of watch what plays out
play out was yeah that's the qualities
we want to look for mindfulness did you
ever think that anything was in your
body that there was something going on
inside of your body no I mean I felt
like something was trying to take over
my body like I said I thought something
was trying to like something from some
other dimension was trying to go through
my mind what about in your butt or
anything like that like seriously that
seems like such like a you know it's
like a good place to store something boy
yeah I actually I mean I did have there
was one thing that [ __ ] with me
because I had this dream once the before
try starting to go man if I wasn't fully
manic I had this dream where as a dream
within a dream and I saw this perfect
weight that was like what LSD looks like
and then I popped out and I got a and I
had this like glowing bit of like
glitter thing and I was like everything
has like this around it when you're on
LSD and I got to remember this and I was
I knew I was in a dream and I was
talking with my girlfriend and heard her
friend and they're always sharing dreams
with one
another insides like I got to remember
this when I'm done with this dream how
do I remember this and they were like
I'll just put it in your butt and as I
could excuse me like oh if you all
remember a dream just sit on it yeah
just put it in your butt and I was like
what you're like you better hurry up and
put on your butt and then you'll
remember I was like oh I guess so and
then I sat on it and then I woke up and
I remembered every detail of my dream
and and that's when I psych out welcome
onna if you want to remember something
you'll never forget anything that goes
in here but it's true and so we know the
memory bank that's the devil satchel and
so but after that when I did go manic
then that was [ __ ] with me okay I put
a secret in my body silly trick yeah
is there a trick in my butt right now
yeah yeah I had a little bit of that
[ __ ] with me yeah but there was I
mean I had so many different the reason
why if you're like dude only this
happened and I'm like yes the idea
because I had every [ __ ] conceivable
possibility of anything that could be
happening
I had it man it was never-ending and
[ __ ] exhausting sounds exhausting it
was it was exhausting do you feel like
life's at the right speed now mm-hmm ya
know yeah I mean I'm like now I'm Mike
with my a new tour standup science I'm
just like mostly a [ __ ] business guy
I'm just sending out emails to people
you were and doing [ __ ] work yeah I
loved a lot of a stand-up that was in
the in the documentary too man oh really
cool stuff yet there was one point I
can't run what it was man I was just
laughing out loud but yeah you have to
check out where converters get it
well it's available on March 5th on
Amazon ok and and then
it will be available for pre-sale on
January 22nd I want to say let's say
23rd to be safe ok January 23rd will be
available for pre-sale so that that'll
help me out if people are excited about
it and get those presale numbers up then
it when it hits the amazon page it'll
launch it up there and be recommended to
more people and all that on the release
so I liked it man I thought it was a
good thing if you want to share with
somebody a little bit about like you
know a parent even to sit with a parent
or family member to teach them you know
have them have a little bit of an idea
of what doing psychedelics is like in
some of these different drugs it was
great man psycho nautics psycho knotek's
a Comics exploration of psychedelics and
that's all on my website Shane moss I'm
a USS comm it was brave I thought it was
brave how vulnerable you were in some
moments Thanks you know even just in the
way of like wow he's you know like you
know he's gonna do drugs which make you
sometimes unaware of what's going on
with yourself on a camera and know that
that's gonna go out to everybody that's
uh
I mean I almost wanted to see more of
that I think at times yeah buying I
wanted to show more that too but it just
we got what we but we got I thought we
were going to have more time to film
this stuff I thought there's going to be
just lots more opportunities to capture
more nuts and then I want nuts and so we
we had what we had to work with and and
I'm really happy with how it all came
out yeah yeah man me too but there's
some moments that are just so like I'm
like oh it feels like I'm tripping you
know it feels like I'm [ __ ] up on
mushrooms it feels like well thanks
that's what we're going for
yeah and we wanted it to feel a little
bit like a trip also a producer
premature Nick is from all across
Wisconsin and uh well I also want to say
just personal hero mine you had seven
underage drinking tickets I believe I
owe or hi at eleven eleven eleven I was
searching
and underage drinking tonight for didn't
even get here but yeah there really yeah
an unattainable legacy but I was gonna
say there's a lot of visual graphical
like visual representations of your
trips like as you're describing them in
the documentary did you have input to
the people that are making that does
that some do they Eric resonate because
like that's the image when I think about
tripping like it's what we see it's like
seeing a painting of God well so there's
this guy sander boss who is this amazing
animator who he basically just smokes
DMT and then makes animations oh he
knows what the DMT experience and he his
animations are the closest thing to a
visual representation of what a DMT trip
is actually like that I've ever seen and
I've known him for a few years and we've
been kind of collaborating on some
things and so I just
we just used some of his pre-existing
stuff that that was like some of the
things that I saw because there are like
very similar a lot of similarities and
people like people smoked DMT and a lot
of people see the same sorts of worlds
and then I had an animator Ramin nazar
make custom stuff for me and he's he's a
good friend of mine who is this amazing
comic book artist and animator that that
has a lot of experience with
psychedelics so he is able to represent
things really well so is a mix of both
cool cool
yet sometimes it's just really hacky and
movies and stuff although they'll do it
I know that's what we are trying to
avoid did it yeah and then how to how to
make this stuff represent it visually
well I was really happy with how it all
came out because I was nervous about
that Wow yeah did you realize how much
you have to trust the director and that
sort of thing yeah I mean Brian crushed
it I
I was skeptical I didn't think he's
gonna be able to pull off the film that
that he was able to make yeah and he did
I know he's a smart guy man do do we
have any more questions dick they were
good well good um do we uh what would
you recommend to somebody like what is
how is it DMT use one time gonna help
someone I don't think that it is okay I
think that DMT use is the single most
interesting experience that you could
ever have in your life and at the same
time there's no like valuable life
lesson it's just such a jarring bizarre
paradoxical place that there's nothing
grounded in this reality that you're
gonna be like and now I'm gonna exercise
more I think I think if you want to if
you're looking for self-improvement
I think mushrooms are just a great way
to learn about yourself and if you're
too scared about going too far or scenes
seems a little too far out for you or
whatever MDMA is just like the easiest
you don't have to worry about anyone
having a bad trip or anything like that
it's if anything is it's like it can be
a little bit of a party drug but I
recommend taking it as like do it with
uh in like a couple situation there's
like a really nice situation to do MDMA
in yeah you said I remember hearing you
say you and your girlfriend like shared
things you would never share and like
really like brought you guys closer
together yeah
what about do do people like so if
someone's gonna have mushrooms can they
just do them like by themselves at home
I mean I've done them before when I was
saying for our listeners I've heard
could they get something I mean is there
a way to like have a cell what's the
best way to have a self exploration
experience yeah I mean ketamine you can
do in a clinical setting with an actual
professional there for you so then you
can have you can have this pretty
intense disassociative experience in a
in a professional setting and and if
or that or not not really I think in
some places that it will but it's worth
looking into that that's hopefully in
the future there will be these like
clinical settings where that'll be like
almost like a trip school right where
you'd where you do it the right way
first with people and then you can
explore on your own but I really like
that in Los Angeles we can go into a
ketamine clinic oh yeah Wow I recommend
just the best thing to do would be to
join like a local psychedelic group and
just find like-minded people in your
area and start the conversation that way
and don't walk in there first time be
like hey does anyone know where I can
get mushrooms yeah you just want to go
in there and like listen and hear what
people have to say and check it out and
yeah and tell them what brought you in
there and they can guide you from there
I mean psychedelic the psychedelic
community is just like the cooling
smartest awesome that great best people
out there and it's growing fast and if
you really want to get in touch with
someone you can always calm down a drain
and see you here is it hey man I've
always said you're one of the best joke
writers dude and you have such a unique
style and really I'm soaked off like as
I watched it I felt envious man of
watching the movie oh thanks oh wow he
met like he made like he you know yeah
you know something I first I didn't want
my standup to be in the movie and then
when I saw what Brian was able to do
with it it really helped move the story
along and keep it fun and so I was like
yeah go for it
and so I was really happy with how it
came out and how I'm represented in it
yeah and do mushroomy since growing so
fast so many times I'll see people out
of bars and clubs now and there are some
mushrooms they're not not even drinking
or say just you know weirdest micro -
somewhere is mushroom you know know
everybody's on mushrooms
it's happening yeah it's happening this
is it Shane Moss you can find his tour
dates yeah Seamus calm
my show stand up science I'm taking to
about 40 different cities between now
and March and or April anyway and so go
there I'm going all over the place and
adding more dates all the time
yeah awesome and uh on behalf of uh Nick
from La Crosse Wisconsin as well and
myself thank you so much for being here
thank you yeah we'll see you soon around
another realm I hope connect through the
drain yeah the little [ __ ] drain gang
[Music]
little town for me to slap that parking
brake can let myself
[Music]